this morning john berko the former house
of commons speaker has
defected to the labour party a
conservative since his youth he served
as a conservative mp from 1997
until 2009 before occupying the
speaker's chair for a decade
government sources have told sky news
they're not surprised by the defection
after bitter rouse over brexit
made him many enemies in his former
party
well for his first tv interview about
the decision i'm joined here in studio
by john burko trevor good morning to you
good morning um 25 years
a long time why leave now
after all that time well i was a member
of the conservative party for 29 years
but robert buckland spoke truer than he
knew
when he said that i left the
conservative party a long time ago
let's be crystal clear explicit
and accurate trevor i became speaker on
the 22nd of june 2009
and that evening in conformity with
convention i wrote to the then chairman
of the conservative party eric pickles
to tender my resignation as a member of
the conservative party
why because the speaker does not belong
to is
independent of separate from unconnected
with it
no support for operations that's a
different decision any political party
it's a different decision you could have
rejoined when you stepped down
as speaker 18 months ago why didn't i
could have rejoined the conservative
party i didn't have the slightest desire
to do so and i
want to be fundamentally
clear and for there to be no dubai about
this
as i said yesterday to an observer
journalist
my values are left of center i do not
identify with the conservative party
and i think that in british politics
you've just heard from ed davey
most people still see it as principally
a choice between the conservative party
and the labour party
and the labour party is the alternative
government
to the conservative party if you believe
as i do
that this government is bad news unfit
to govern and that the prime minister
though a successful campaigner is a
lousy governor
you have to ask yourself do you want rid
of it and if you want rid of it
you have then to pose to yourself the
question and to answer it
how is that to be achieved and the
reality of the matter is in
the united kingdom the only credible
vehicle for the
removal of this government
is the election of a labor government
committed equality
social justice internationalism and a
fairer
and more inclusive society that's the
labor brand i know you're a person who
chooses your words very carefully john
you you've used as expression this
governments
uh i think three or four times this
morning at what point did you decide
you couldn't be a conservative was it
when the conservative party
was taken over by boris johnson or was
it something that changed in you
no it was something that changed in me
and i think oh so it's not boring i owe
it to myself
and to you and to everybody else to be
on the record about it and for there to
be no
uncertainty so if you're saying to me is
it principally about boris johnson the
honest answer that is
no and in fact there has been i think
already some confusion and
misrepresentation of that point
it's not personal against boris johnson
i do think that
he is someone who has only a nodding
acquaintance with the truth in elite
year
and i think that the utter contempt with
which he has treated parliament is
lamentable
and i think it has exacerbated the very
strong feelings of
resentment towards him because i think a
lot of people feel that's not the way to
behave
telling the truth in and to parliament
matters circumventing parliament
is wrong treating parliament with
disdain is objectionable
but no i have over a long period evolved
my political thinking
i wasn't a member of a party throughout
my tenure tenure
as speaker because it would have been
quite wrong to be
i didn't take a view i sought to
facilitate the house of commons to
express
its view and all individual members to
put their points across because that's
the responsibility
of the speaker now i'm a private citizen
as robert buckland says
i'm entitled to take a political view
and my view is a left-of-center view
i identify with labor values labour
principles labour policies i'm going to
come to labor in a second but
um you've used the words xenophobic
nationalistic you have not just said
some
let's say less than fond things about
boris johnson it's the party you don't
like isn't it
and you don't like conservatives anymore
well i don't dislike
individual conservatives i have still a
number of conservative friends and i can
admire
and respect very much trevor people
across the political spectrum with a
vast miscellany of different views
on the understanding that they're honest
and principled and standing up
for the principles in which they believe
so it's not a question of personalities
it's a question of the issues but if you
say do i like the conservative party
the answer is no and i'm absolutely
clear
that i am not these days a conservative
so it's not
about boris johnson as tony benn used to
say it's not about personalities
it's about policies all right um you
know what they're saying aren't they
boris johnson didn't give you a period
and kiersten will
now give that up well i can answer that
very simply i've had absolutely no
discussion whatsoever either with kia
stammer
or any other member of the labour
leadership about that matter there has
been no barter no trade
no deal whatsoever and if i may very
politely say so
and i do the people who make what they
think
is that potent and coruscating criticism
of me
are operating according to their own
rather low standards let's deal with the
issue rather than impugn people's
motives it's got
nothing to do with that whatsoever
before before we leave that
leader of the opposition conceivable you
might be watching this program
it might be occurring to him right now i
must bring up john and offer him a
period if he were to do that
what would you say well i think there's
a lot to be said trevor
for the old willy white law
adage personally i think it is best to
cross bridges
only when one comes to them it isn't in
my mind it's not part of the game plan i
haven't discussed it i'm not waiting for
it
what i'm motivated by is a commitment to
equality
social justice and internationalism i
believe
absolutely passionately and these are
the issues
that on leveling up the government
mouths the mantra
but it doesn't know the meaning of the
mantra if you
look at the recent record the
government's own education czar said 15
000 million pounds is needed to level up
and the government has offered less than
one-tenth of that
let's focus on the issues slashing the
aid budget
it's wrong it's objectionable utterly
shameful
we talk about these things a lot on this
program but um
you know we have the excitement of
having you here this morning so let's
talk about
you um it could be said
that this is a typical berko grand
gesture
to avoid speculation
it's part of your legacy uh of the
criticism
of you uh as presiding over a culture of
bullying in the house
houses of parliament how do you respond
to that
that this is not really what you're
about what you're really trying to do
is to bury all of that i'm not trying to
bury anything
i think the suggestion that i presided
over that culture
is quite wrong i'm not going to talk
about individual instances
because there is a confidentiality about
that process which shouldn't be
compromised
or disrespected in any way i can just
say however there was
one individual who brought a complaint
of bullying against me
it was investigated and it was rejected
but i put to you again trevor and i
appreciate you've got your journalistic
responsibility
let's focus on the issues as far as i'm
concerned
issues that's what caused me to make
photos
um speak honestly to me
i always do do you can you say that you
never did anything that you felt now
you regret or you thought might have
been objectionable
or that might have been something that
when you look back now you think
i wish i hadn't done that oh in relation
to this issue
of bullying and so on gosh i would have
to cast my mind back we all make
mistakes
have i been perfect in every instance
can i say
that with the benefit of high insight
i'd never have done something
differently of course i couldn't but i
come back to the central proposition
one has as a private citizen the right
to make a judgment about which political
parties are support
i believe in terms of values the labour
party is preferable to the conservative
party and as far as kierstama is
concerned i don't know
whether he's going to make it
politically or not but i think he's an
honest decent intelligent person who has
come into politics
as the continuation of public service
and the real issue in my mind is who
has the vision of a more equitable
society who
thirsts to deliver social mobility who
wants to better the lot of people
less fortunate than a political leader
on on
that calculus is vastly preferable
tomorrow you've talked about labour's
values and policies
i have to confess i've been doing this
program for some weeks now
i've yet to drag anything that looked
like a policy out of a labour
spokesperson
what is the policy or value that you
think labor has that really offers this
i'll give you two examples one domestic
and one international
a domestic commitment to leveling up on
the proper funding
of education so that those who have been
dramatically damaged as a consequence of
the pandemic have the chance to recover
that's the first
example and the second example which
speaks to the dna of a progressive party
is that the labour party thinks it is
utterly wrong
and immoral to slash the aid budget
cutting provision for the poorest and
most destitute people on the face of the
planet who don't live
on a dollar a day they exist on a dollar
a day
okay that is wrong okay period i'm
afraid i have to ask pretty much
everybody
who um has experienced government and
been
seen in conservative party this today um
matt hancock
completely useless or what well i think
it would be fair for me to say
that i would buy matt at
my valuation and sell him at his
and realize a healthy profit in the
process
i think i've worked out exactly what
that means
well we'll see how hancock's fair thank
you very much
uh sean berker trevor thank you very
much indeed good morning to you